Sophie Chung begins her day with boxing
training at 7:00 a.m. she could knock
out a much larger opponent if she wanted
to but that's not the point
boxing is actually a very technical
sport very complex it doesn't look like
that at first glance but there are
various punches which can land correctly
or not
you notice very quickly for me boxing is
a combination of power strength and
stamina she has no problems encroaching
into what some might see as a male
domain personally I wish there were more
women who practice martial arts whether
boxing or karate the world needs more
female Klitschko's and more female Steve
Jobs women's startup founders are still
very much the exception Jonah is
actually a doctor but since 2015 she's
been running a platform for medical
tourism that matches patients with
hospitals worldwide it's made 40,000
batches so far in the world of business
she's typically surrounded by men I wish
women were bolder in many situations
maybe direct less criticism and doubted
themselves and show determination trust
themselves and go out into the world and
start something up the biggest hurdle in
founding a company is getting investors
to put money into it Chung was looking
to raise 1.7 million euros from the two
investors here and she got it thanks to
her confidence and powers of persuasion
you have to convince and motivate your
team you have to win over possible
investors to fund it and to believe in
the company to be convincing and that's
most certainly one of Sophie's strengths
I need a fan who does good alpha males
meet good alpha females and work as a
team together
chum used to work as a management
consultant
Mukunda when you're setting things up
you encounter a lot of resistance you
have huge responsibilities and you have
to make decisions every day you need
nerves of steel she'll need all her
expertise today she has an appointment
at the unfuck honking house Berlin the
renowned Berlin trauma treatment center
is about to start admitting patients
referred here from her online platform
Sophie Chong says that even today most
decision-makers in business are men of
course it's frustrating to see that
there's still inequality between men and
women I think the way that I've opened
up is my contribution to changing that I
wish that there were more women doctors
who can aspire to a career a
professorship or to become director of a
hospital a small ice cream break in the
park with her staff that's part of the
corporate culture in her company but so
are all-nighters and an uncertain future
Chung knows that both those things scare
off many women from starting businesses
female role models could help dispel
some of those fears there's definitely a
lack of role models I see that with
myself there are hardly any successful
women that I personally can look up to
as an example and that's the way it is
with many things in life when there
aren't any role models when there's
fewer people who have experienced how it
functions then it's something hard for
young people to picture and then you
lose courage sometimes almost half of
Sophie Chong's employees are women the
boss says that's just by accident she
doesn't give women any special
privileges in her company